bene a tutti ragazzi per questo nuovo
video sono pa vj oggi sono dati su dopo
non lo facevo
riproviamoci sexy oggi provo la modalità
bomba zar che è praticamente la modalità
più difficile perché tu parti che hai
solo due familiari quindi se fai schifo
primo e secondo ai pochissime profili se
hai molta più probabilità di fare schifo
in quello che fa e quindi come me a
scuola più il problema dei ragazzi se
riusciamo a fare quanto riusciamo a
campare questa modalità vabbè
specialmente non ho niente non so se
qualcuno è mai riuscito a vincere in
questa modalità io neanche in facile
vinco tutti quelli che vedete che lo
fanno su youtube lo fanno in easy o in
normal ma normal nemmeno lo fanno quasi
tutti il 99 per cento lo fa imi easy e
non vinci mai lo stesso tende non
dobbiamo preoccuparci per lui lavora
niente nessuno mangia nessuno fa nulla i
livelli in continuazione contaminazione
sono ancora molto alti quindi niente
a quanto pare abbiamo già il nostro
personale orto post apocalittico ma ho
trovato gli strani funghi che riuscivano
suoi paletti bagnatevi quelli vediamo
quanto duro nagano sono sincero ma sono
radiati esatto tutti e due malati
ok partenza orribile oggi aver imparato
una cosa la zuppa di motore la nostra
migliore amica no è l'acqua costa mia
amica zuppa la seconda i funghi
decisamente no mary jane si è presa
qualcosa di brutto la scabbia guarda
lavante bella chiama avanti ragazzi
almeno a cui almeno 15 almeno il giorno
15 non arriverò mai al giorno e vabbè
ragazzi mando fuori ted anche perché non
ho più acqua quindi devo assolutamente
mandare fuori tende vai ci sia salute
mary jane
ci siamo nel momento dell'uscita veit ed
sei tutti noi ce la faremo
tranquilli a posto non vi preoccupate
tutto tutto fatto tutto gente
consideratelo già tornato giorno 16
record battuto in modalità difficile
abbiamo giocato a fare la lista 2 chi
però ok ma fai la lista delle cose che
ho di di più ci è venuto in mente che
quel difficile dalla cassaforte saluta
il vicino bye bye bye bye bye mary jane
bayrou balle roba da vicino by 17 vai
cosa hai rubato virginio la fa verona 6
la lebbra ok niente niente
intanto the dead non ne vuole sapere di
tornare morti posto che è successo ed è
là fuori da troppo tempo e non ha ancora
fatto ritorno abbiamo la sensazione che
non torna più regola numero uno ma
andare fuori i componenti inutili della
famiglia perché quelli utili se muoiono
finisce la partita spero che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi questa è la modalità di
film lo scherzo ovviamente facciamo un
altro 18 giorni sopravvivenza o di sfida
riproviamo stavolta mando fuori qualcuno
subito e vediamo cosa riesco a fare
secondo me se mando fuori ma ritiene
meglio perché se schiatta mary jane
almeno ted rimane vivo e posso ancora
sopravvivere perché se no non è un senso
quindi tentiamo di battere il giorno 18
vincerò mai in questa modalità ma tutto
è tutto sta nel sopravvivere il più
possibile ma come hanno sbagliato
modalità sorry allora al giorno 1 bene
oggi mia moglie cia tesoro abbiamo molta
più acqua attenzione manderei col fuori
subito mia moglie subito pan cattiveria
al se muore non me ne sbatto le balle
fatto l'importante è che sopravviva ted
subito fuori subito via via via via via
via via via come se niente fosse
trattato gli strani funghi non
assaggiare niente che ti viene la
scabbia
let's golf o ti viene la pietri te
quella brutta fuori la mamma con la
maschera let's go by ritorno zia e mi
raccomando ti voglio con otto bottiglie
che poi morirai tu perché avrei preso la
contaminazione nonno perché c'è la
maschera attenzione qui non è
contaminata le anche volendo attenzione
potrei aver fatto una provata
incredibile maledizione mogli e torna
eccola di uniti ha portato il carrefour
brava grande è stato un sacco di
bottiglie peccato che ho preso la
malaria dolores e tornata fantastico e
io manderei a questo punto di spedizione
ted acqua e cibo
e chissenefrega vediamo se stavolta
potrebbe avere un senso di tornarmi vivo
tel
mi raccomando giorno 13 lett.d dolores
hai meritato dell'acqua la vuoi dolore
sono sopravvivere a lungo senza acqua
allora acqua e cibo brava dolores ma
cagata dietro l'altra ho fatto ma niente
male perché volesse tornata con le robe
bravissima dolore se lo mangia lavori
operato nel cibo in opel ha fatto il
record è di 118
abbiamo eguagliato il record attenzione
almeno un giorno in più o meno 19 dove
mio marito è scomparso dalla faccia
della terra è tornato adesso è tornato
alla zuppa bravo bravissimo
ok sono più tetto adesso quanto ecco
altrove sopravvivere
dolores potrebbe sopravvivere la fuori
allora invece di lasciarla morire sapete
che vi dico lavando fuori tanto tempo e
morire per morire chi se ne frega by
fuori e io rimango solo con te vediamo
quanto riesco a sopravvivere io l'amante
ray con la mappa almeno teoricamente se
la porta dietro dovrebbe avere un po di
più o meno dove riuscì a orientarsi veit
ed solo io e te siamo non toccare niente
non toccare niente vai avanti fino al 28
brava dolores e tornata bravissima o
come bellissimo ma brava cos'ha portato
problema per bene a bordo tre madonna se
portare se avessi portato un kit finanze
giorno 60 sopravvivere ma niente brava
dovesse sei stata bravissima e un
peccato se non fosse che non ti posso
abita da mangiare perché devo dare tutto
a dead se no non sono tutto attende non
posso massimizzare il record che mi
morita entrambi quindi devo tenere la
vita ted dolores può morire frega niente
ho mandato i ragazzi a prendere le
provviste da dei bambini a rubarle ci
abbia fatta mi sa di no
i kit il kit non ci credo non ci credo
vado anni perfetto ma dai ma da il kit
detto se curato madonna non ci credo
tete curato 40 e provviste abbiamo
giorno 31 al 32 acqua per te mia moglie
sta morendo chi se ne frega però sta
resistendo e mia moglie senza acqua né
cibo non troppo però acqua e cibo per te
ragazzi c'è un sacco di roba un sacco di
roba perfetto frega niente dei ragazzi
siamo giorno 33 ragazzi sta modalità
incredibile 8 piatto record di prima
quasi al giorno 36 o doppiatore con di
prima ed è in ottima forma per una
spedizione ma sai che ti mando ti mando
per un motivo così almeno passare i
giorni in fretta e soprattutto ti mando
con la valigia perché la valigia ti
mette dentro la la maschera e la mappa
così tu sai orientarti e non morì per le
radiazioni quindi vai fidati vai vai vai
tranquillo
questa con la maschera e la mappa ok
pericoli non è morto c'è un altro kit
sono approfitterà del corpo non è morto
non è morto e allora e allora ha preso
anche la valigetta guardano proprio lui
due acque più il kit meno la maschera
chi se ne frega molto bene molto bene
guarda quanto modalità difficile prima
che ci stiamo a fare qualsiasi cosa
fuoco ha danneggiato alcuni dei nostri
averi
no dai ma posso mai dai ma proprio qui
tra tutte ma dai ma 10.000 valigia la
mappa la radio è già rotta le carte mi
gamal chi te lo dò il kiter nuovo giorno
60 ragazzi siamo al sessantesimo
[Musica]
devo farlo mangiare tra due giorni ok
madonna sto scappando tutto per non dare
niente a nessuno c'è una roba
inguardabile
allora se sopravvive adesso lo faccio
mangiare ok adesso mangia e poi beve
domani ok
aprite in nome della libertà che gli
davano fuori dalla porta non eravamo
sicuri di chi fosse ma si capiva che si
trattava di un gruppo di persone forse
armate
chiunque si presenta così sta di certo
progetto di uscire qualcuno in nome
della libertà che si fa me la sento già
potuto le provviste no celato fucile
meno male che deretano ragazzi
incredibile
sta andando tutto bene 66 imbarazzante
ryan no no perché no no no no no no no
no perché quella besser il retour à ha
vinto ci ha sconfitti e rovato il nostro
cibo consente quindi a era malato no la
malattia che l'ha portato via
ma dai no perché
che sfiga perché lui gli stavo dando le
giuste provviste potevamo sopravvivere
anche fino al 90 100 no ma secondo me a
90 potevamo arrivarci che brutta frase
ho detto no ragazzi incredibile che
sfiga o eravamo arrivati al 18 è dove
qua guarda quanto fatto in più
72 e potevo andare molto più avanti se
non mi si fosse bruciato il kit sennò mi
si fosse bruciato il chiti a quest'ora
avrei fatto un punteggio che già è alto
ma spaziale l'avrei fatto porca vacca
se non vi si fosse bruciato il kit
nell'incendio porca vacca che si
incredibile avrei fatto almeno 90 di
mortacci ma vabbè dai ragazzi spero che
sia piaciuto si accederà campanella per
rimanere aggiornati sui nei video che
escono iscrivetevi al canale perché è
una cosa molto importante ma la
campanella
ragazzi siamo suonata la campanella
macchina ma chi fa quanto maletti sono
suonate da campanelli la cia dove mi
piace un commento su cosa ne pensi dei
ragazzi o ha fatti gli scherzi che sarà
buona è va bene tutto
e come al solito noi ci vediamo il
prossimo vino bello ragazzi
[Musica]